All right.
Good morning everyone.
My name is lise Friedman.
I'm a research scientist here at Mit.
I build the autonomous vehicles and
perception systems for these vehicles.
And today I,
I'd like to talk to him.
First of all was great to be a part of
this amazing course and intro to deep
learning.
Um,
it's,
it's a wonderful course covering a
pretty quickly but deeply,
uh,
some of the fundamental aspects of deep
learning.
This is awesome.
So the topic that I'm perhaps most
passionate about from the perspective of
just being a researcher in artificial
intelligence is deep reinforcement
learning,
which is a set of ideas and methods that
teach agents to act in the real world.
Okay.
If you think about what machine learning
is,
it allows us to make sense of the world,
but to truly have impact in the physical
world,
we need to also act in that world.
So you bring the understanding of that
you extract from the world through the
perception systems and actually decide
to make actions.
So you can think of intelligence systems
as this kind of stack from the top to
the bottom and the environment.
At the top of the world that the Asian
operates in.
And at the bottom is the factors that
actually make,
uh,
changes to the world by moving the
robot,
moving the agent in a way that changes
the world,
that acts in the world.
And so from the environment it goes to
the sensors sensing the raw sensory
data,
extracting the features,
making sense of that features,
understanding for me representations
higher and higher order representations
from those representations,
we gain knowledge that's useful,
actionable.
Finally,
we reason the thing that we hold so dear
as human beings,
the reasoning that builds and aggregates
knowledge bases and using that reasoning
form short term and long term plans to
finally turn into action and act in that
world,
changing it.
So that's kind of the stack of
artificial intelligence.
And the question is how much in the same
way as human beings,
we learn most of the stack when we're
born,
we know very little and we'd take in
five sensory,
uh,
sources of sensory data and make sense
of the world,
learn over time to act successful in
that world.
How much?
The question is can we use deep learning
methods to learn parts of the stack,
the modules of the stack or the entire
stack end to end?
Let's go over them.
Okay,
so for uh,
robots that act in the world,
autonomous vehicles,
humanoid,
robots,
drones,
there are sensors,
whether it's slide our camera and
microphone coming from the audio
networking for the communications,
I am you getting the kinematics of the
different vehicles.
That's the raw data coming in.
That's the eyes,
ears,
nose for robots.
Then the ones who have the sensory data,
the task is to form representations on
data.
Yeah.
You make sense of this raw pixels,
a raw piece,
pieces,
samples for whatever the sensor is and
you start to try to piece it together
into something that can be used to gain
understanding.
It's just numbers and those numbers need
to be converted into something that can
be reasoned with.
That's forming representations and
that's where machine learning,
deep learning steps in and takes this
raw sensory data.
The was some preprocessing,
some profit,
some initial processing,
and for forming higher and higher order
representation in that data that can be
reasoned with about in the computer
vision from edges two faces,
two entire entities.
And finally the interpretation,
the semantic interpretation of the
scene.
That's machine learning,
playing with the representations and the
reasoning part.
One of the exciting fundamental open
challenges of machine learning is how
does this greater and greater
representation that can be formed
through deep neural networks can then
lead to reasoning,
to building knowledge,
not just,
uh,
a memorization task,
which is taking a supervised learning,
memorizing patterns in the input data
based on human annotations,
but also an extracting those patterns,
but also then taking that knowledge and
building over time as we humans do,
building into something that can be
called common sense and to knowledge
basis in a very trivial task.
This means,
uh,
aggregating fusing multiple types of,
multiple,
uh,
types of extraction of knowledge.
So from image recognition,
you could think if it looks like a duck
in an image,
it sounds like a duck when the audio and
then you could do act activity
recognition with the video.
Uh,
it a swims like a duck and it must be a
duck.
Just aggregating this trivial,
uh,
different sources of information.
That's reasoning.
Now I think a form the human perspective
from the very biased human perspective,
one of the,
uh,
illustrative aspects of reasoning is
theory improving is the moment of
invention,
of creative genius of this breakthrough
ideas as we humans come up with and mean
really these aren't new ideas.
Whenever we come up with an interesting
idea,
they're not new.
We're just collecting pieces of high
word representations of knowledge that
we've gained over time and then piecing
them together to form something,
some simple beautiful distillation that
is useful for,
uh,
for the rest of the world.
And,
uh,
one of my favorite,
sort of human stories and discoveries in
pure theorem improving is from Oslo.
Last theorem.
It stood for 358 years.
This is a trivial thing to explain.
Most a six,
well,
eight year olds can understand the
definition of the,
uh,
the conjecture that x,
the n plus y to the n equals z to the n
has no solution for and greater than a
three greater than you going to the
three.
Okay.
This,
this has been unsolved,
has been,
uh,
hundreds of thousands of people try to
solve it.
And,
uh,
finally Andrew wiles from Oxford and
Princeton had this final breakthrough
moment in,
uh,
1994.
So he first approved in 1993 and then it
was shown that he failed.
And then,
so that's,
that's the,
the human drama.
And then night.
So he had a,
uh,
he spent a year trying to find the
solution.
And there's this moment,
this final breakthrough 358 years after
this first form that buy from us as a
conjecture.
He,
he,
uh,
he said it was so incredibly beautiful.
It was so simple,
so elegant.
I couldn't understand how I missed it
and I just stared at it and this belief
for 20 minutes,
this is him finally closing the loop,
figuring out the final proof.
I just stared at it and,
but disbelief for 20 minutes.
Then during the day I walked around the
department and I keep coming back to my
desk looking to see if it was still
there.
It was still there.
I couldn't contain myself.
I was so excited.
It was the most important moment of my
working life.
Nothing I ever done,
nothing I ever do again,
we'll mean as much.
So this moment of breakthrough,
how do we teach neural networks?
How do we learn from data to achieve
this level of breakthrough?
That's the open question that I want you
to sort of walk away from this part a of
the lecture thinking about what is the
future of agents that think,
and Alexandra,
we'll talk about the new future
challenges next,
but what can we use deep reinforcement
learning to extend past the memorization
pass pack pattern recognition into
something like reasoning and achieving
this breakthrough moment.
And at the very least something a
brilliantly in 1995 after Andrew Weil's
homer Simpson and,
and those are fans of the simpsons
actually proved them wrong.
This is very interesting.
Uh,
so he found an example where it does
hold true the Pharmas Theorem,
uh,
to a certain number of digits after the
period.
Okay.
And then finally,
aggregating this knowledge into action.
That's what deeper enforcement learning
is about.
Extracting patterns from raw data and
then finally being able to estimate the
state of the world around the agent in
order to make successful action that
completes a certain goal.
Uh,
so,
and I will talk about the difference
between agents that are learning from
data and agents that are currently
successfully being able to operate in
this world.
Example,
the agents here from Boston dynamics I
ones that don't use any deeper
enforcement learning,
they don't use any,
they don't learn from data.
This is the open gap,
the challenge that we have to solve.
How do we use reinforcement learning
methods,
build robots,
agents that act in the real world,
that learn from that world.
Uh,
except for the perception task.
So in this stack,
you can think from the environment to
the effectors that promise the beautiful
power of deep learning is taking the raw
sensory data and being able to,
in an automated way.
Do feature learning to extract arbitrary
high order representations on that data.
So it makes sense of the patterns in
order to be able to learn in supervise,
learning to learn the mapping of those
patterns.
Arbitrarily high order representations
on those patterns to uh,
to,
uh,
to extract actionable useful knowledge
that's in the red box.
So the promise of deep reinforcement
learning why it's so exciting for
okay.
Uh,
artificial intelligence community,
why it captivates our imagination and
about the possibility towards achieving
human level.
General intelligence is that you can
take not just the end to end extraction
of a knowledge from raw sensory data.
You can also do end to end from raw
sensory data,
be able to produce actions to brute
force,
learn from the raw data,
the uh,
the semantic,
uh,
context,
the meaning of the world around you in
order to successfully act in that world
and to end just like we humans do.
That's the promise.
Okay.
But,
uh,
we're in the very early stages of,
um,
of achieving that promise.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
and successful presentation must include
cats.
So supervised learning and unsupervised
learning and reinforcement learning sits
in the middle,
was a supervised learning.
Most of the,
uh,
the data has to come from the human.
They're the insights about what is
inside the data has to come from human
annotations.
And it's the task of the machine to
learn how to generalize based on those
human annotations over future examples
it hasn't seen before.
And unsupervised learning,
you have no human annotation.
S reinforcement learning is somewhere in
between,
closer on unsupervised learning or the
annotations from humans.
The information and knowledge from
humans,
it's very sparse,
extremely sparse.
And so you have to use the temporal
dynamics,
the fact that in time these,
the,
uh,
the continuity of our world through
time,
you have to use the sparse little
rewards you have along the way to extend
that over the entirety of,
uh,
the,
the temporal domain to make some sense
of the world,
even though the rewards are really
sparse.
Those are the two cats learning,
uh,
the Pavlov's cats,
if you will.
Learning that I had to ring the door,
ring the bell in order to get some food.
That's the basic for them,
the reinforcement learning problem.
So from supervised learning,
you can think of those networks as
memorizers reinforcement learning is you
can think of them of crudely.
So as sort of brute force reasoning,
trying to propagate rewards into
extending how to make sense of the world
in order to act in it.
The pieces are simple.
There's an environment,
there's an agent,
it takes actions in that agent.
It senses the environment so there's
always a state of the agent senses.
And then I always,
when taking an action received some kind
of reward or punishment from that world
so we can model any kind of world in
this way.
They can model an arcade game breakout
here,
Atari breakout,
the engine has the capacity to act,
move the paddle.
It has a,
it can influence the future state of the
system by taking those actions and then
it's uses a award.
There's a goal to this game.
The goal is to maximize teacher award.
They could model the card call balancing
problem where the,
you can control the polling angle,
angle or speed.
You can control the cart position,
the horizontal velocity,
the actions of that is the pushing the
cart,
applying the force of the cart.
And the task is to balance the poll.
Okay.
And their award is one at each time
step,
the pull still upright.
That's the goal.
So that's a simple formulation of state
action reward.
You can play a game of doom with the
state being the raw pixels of the,
of the game and the actions that are
moving the uh,
the player around shooting and the
reward,
a positive one at eliminating an
opponent and negative when the agent has
eliminated,
it's just a game,
industrial robotics and you kind of
humanoid robotics when you have to
control multiple degrees of freedom,
control the robotic arm control of the
robot.
The state is the raw pixels of the real
world coming into the sensors of the
robot.
The actions of the possible actions the
robot can take.
So manipulating each of its sensors,
actuators,
sorry,
actuators.
And then their reward is positive and
placing a device successfully negative
otherwise.
So the task is to pick something up,
put it back down.
Okay.
So and I,
I'd like to,
uh,
sort of,
continuing this trajectory further and
further complex systems to think the
biggest challenge for reinforcement
learning is a formulating the world that
we need to solve the set of goals in
such a way that can be,
we can apply these deep reinforcement or
reinforcement learning methods.
So give you an intuition about us
humans.
Uh,
it's exceptionally difficult to
formulate the goals of life.
Was this a survival,
homeostasis,
happiness?
Who knows?
Uh,
uh,
citations depending on who you are.
Uh,
so the state,
the state sight hearing,
taste,
smell,
touch,
that's the raw sensory data actions or
think move.
What else?
I don't know.
And then the reward is just a,
it's open.
All of these questions are open.
So if we want to actually start to
create more and more intelligent
systems,
it's hard to formulate what the goals
are with the state spaces,
with the action spaces.
That's the,
that's if this the,
if you take away anything sort of in a
practical sense from today,
a form from the deeper enforcement
learning part here,
a few slides is that there's a fun part
and a hard part too to all of this work.
So the fun part,
the what this course is about,
I hope it's inspire people about the
amazing,
interesting fundamental algorithms of
deep learning as the fun part.
The hard part is the collecting and
annotating huge amount of representative
data in deep learning and forming higher
representations.
Data does the hard work.
So data is everything.
Once you have good algorithms,
data is everything in deep reinforcement
learning the heart.
The fun part again is these algorithms,
we'll talk about them today,
a little overview them,
but the hard part is defining the world,
the action space and the reward space.
It's just the defining,
formalizing the problem is actually
exceptionally difficult when you start
to try to create,
uh,
an agent that operates in the real world
and actually operate with other human
beings and are actually significantly
helps in the world.
So this isn't playing an arcade game
where everything is clean or playing
chess go.
It's when you're operating in the real
world,
everything is messy.
How do you formalize that?
That's the hard part.
And then the hardest part is getting out
a lot of meaningful data that
represents,
that fits into that formalization that
you formed.
Okay?
In the,
uh,
the mark off decision process that's
underlying the thinking of reinforcement
learning.
There's a state,
you take an action,
receive her award and then observe the
next state.
So it's always state action award state.
That's the sample of data you get as an
agent acting in the world.
State action reward state.
There's a policy where an agent tries to
form a,
uh,
a policy how to act in the world so that
in whatever state it's in,
it,
it has a,
uh,
a preference to a act in a certain way
in order to optimize their award.
There's a value function that can
estimate how good a certain action isn't
a certain state.
And there is sometimes a model that the
agent forms or about the world.
A quick example,
you can have a robot in a room at the
bottom left starting moving about this
room.
It's a three by four grid.
It tries to get to the top right because
it's a plus one,
but because this is the casting system,
when it goes,
chooses to go up,
it's sometimes goes left and right 10%
of the time.
So in this world it has to try to,
uh,
come up with a policy.
So what's a policy?
Is this a solution?
So as starting at the bottom,
arrows show the actions whenever you in
that state that you would like to take.
So this is,
this is a pretty good solution to get to
the plus one in a deterministic world.
And it's the cast,
the quarreled.
Uh,
when you don't,
when you go up,
you don't always go up.
Uh,
it's not a,
a optimal policy because you have to
have an optimum policy,
has to have an answer for every single
state you might be in.
So this,
the outcome policy would look something
like this.
Now that's for when the,
uh,
the costs,
the reward is negative 0.01
for taking a step now feet.
Every time we take a step,
it's really painful.
It's a,
you get a negative to reward.
And so there's a,
the,
the optimal policy changes there is no
matter what,
no matter this tech cast,
the city of the system,
the randomness,
you want to get to the end as fast as
possible.
Even if you go to the negative states,
you just want to get to the plus one as
quickly as possible.
And then,
so the reward structure changes the
optimum policy.
If you make the reward negative 0.1,
then there's some more incentive to
explore.
And as we increase the reward or
decrease the punishment of taking a step
more and more exploration is encouraged
until we get to the kind of,
uh,
what I think of as college,
which is a,
you encourage exploration by having a
positive word to moving around.
And so you never want to get to the end,
you just kinda walk around the world,
uh,
without ever reaching the end.
Okay.
So there's a,
the main goal is to really optimize
reward in this world.
And uh,
because the reward is collected over
time,
you want to have some estimate of future
award and because you don't have a
perfect estimate of the future,
you have to discount that reward over
time.
So the goal is to maximize the
discounted reward over time.
And in cue learning is,
uh,
an approach that,
um,
uh,
that,
I'd like to talk to,
to focus in on today.
The,
there's a state action value cue.
It's a cue function.
It takes an estate in action and it
tells you the value of that state.
It's off policy because,
uh,
we can learn this function without
forming a,
an optimal,
without keeping an optimal policy and
estimate of an optimal policy with us.
And what it turns out with the equation
at the bottom with a bell mini equation,
you can estimate,
uh,
the,
you can update your estimate of the q
function in such a way that over time it
converges to an optimal policy.
And the update is simple.
You have an estimate,
you start knowing nothing.
The A,
there's an old s,
this estimate of an old state q,
s,
a t and then you take an action,
you collect her award and you update
your estimate based on the award he
received and the difference between what
you expected and what you actually
received.
And that's the update you.
So you walk around this world exploring
until he formed better and better
understanding of what is a good action
to take in each individual state.
And there's always as in life and in
reinforcement learning in any agents
that act,
you've,
there's a learning stage where you have
to explore,
exploring pays off when you know very
little.
The more and more you learn,
the less and less valuable it is to
explore.
And you weren't to exploit.
You want to take greedy actions and
that's always the balance you start
exploring at first.
But eventually you want to make some
money.
You whatever the,
the,
the metric of successes and then you
wanted to focus on,
on the policy that you've converge
towards that is pretty good,
uh,
near optimal policy in order to act in a
greedy way.
As you move around with this a bellman
equation,
move around the world,
taking different states,
different actions.
You can update a,
you could think of it as a cute table,
uh,
and you can update the quality of a,
taking a certain action in a certain
state.
So that's a,
that's a,
that's a picture of a table there in the
world with four states and four actions.
And you can move around using the
bellmead equation,
updating the value of being in that
state.
The problem is when this cute table
grows exponentially in order to
represent raw sensory data like we
humans have,
when taking an envision or if you'd
taken the raw pixels of an arcade game,
that's the number of pixels that are
there.
Get is larger than is larger than it can
be stored in memory is largely,
that can be explored.
The simulation,
it's exceptionally large.
And if we know anything about
exceptionally large,
uh,
high dimensional spaces and learning
anything about them,
that's what deep neural networks are
good at.
Forming the approximators,
forming some kind of representation and
exceptionally high dimensional complex,
uh,
space.
So that's the hope for deeper
enforcement learning.
As you take these reinforcement learning
ideas where an agent acts in the world
and learn something about that world.
And we use a neural network as the
approximator as the thing that the agent
uses in order to approximate the
quality,
uh,
either approximate the policy or
approximately the quality of taking
certain actions,
certain state and,
and therefore making sense of this raw
information,
forming,
hiring higher order representations of
the raw sensory information in order to
then as an output,
take an action.
So the neural network is injected as a
function approximator into the queue.
It's,
it's the q function is approximated with
a neural network that's dqn that's deep
cue learning.
So injecting into the cue learning
framework and neural network.
That's what's been the success with deep
mind with the playing the Atar Games.
Having this neural network takes in the
raw pixels of the Atari game and
produces actions of values of each
individual actions.
And then in a greedy way,
picking the best action and the
learning,
the loss function for these networks is
uh,
two folds.
So you have a,
you have a queue function,
an estimate of taking a certain action.
Certain state,
you'd take that action and then you
observe how it's the actual reward
received is different.
So you have a target,
you have a prediction and the loss is
the squared error between those two.
And dqn has used as the same network
that traditional dqn the first,
uh,
yeah.
Dqi uses one network testimate both cues
in that lost function,
uh,
a double Dq,
not dq and uses a separate network for
each one of those a few tricks.
They're key experience replay.
So,
uh,
tricks in reinforcement learning because
the fact that it works is incredible.
And uh,
as as a fundamental sort of
philosophical idea,
knowing so little and being able to make
sense with a,
from such a high dimensional space is
amazing.
But actually these ideas have been
around for quite a long time and a few
key trex is what made them really work.
So in the first,
I think the two things for dqn is
experienced replay is instead of letting
the agent,
uh,
learn as it,
as it acts in the world,
agent is acting in the world and
collecting,
uh,
experiences that can be replayed through
the learning.
So the learning process jumps around
through memory,
through the experiences and instead,
so it doesn't,
um,
it doesn't learn on the local evolution
of a particular stimulation.
Instead learn of the entirety of its
experiences.
Then the fix target network,
as I mentioned with a double Gq n the
fact that the loss function,
uh,
a includes if you notice sort of to,
to forward passes through the neural
network.
And so because when you know,
very little in the beginning,
it's a very unstable system and bias
can,
Eh,
I can have a significant negative
effect.
So there's some benefit in for the
target.
The forward pass the neural network
takes for the target function to,
uh,
to be fixed and only be updated.
Then neural network there to be only
updated every a thousand a hundred
steps.
And there's a few other tricks,
the slides that are available online.
I will,
there's a few interesting bits,
uh,
throughout these slides.
Please check them out.
There's a lot of interesting results
here on the slide.
Uh,
showing the benefit that you get from
these tricks.
So replay experience,
replay and fixed target network are the
biggest.
That's the magic.
That's the thing that made it work for
the Atar Games.
Okay.
And the result was achieving deep mine,
achieving super,
uh,
above human level performance on these
Atari Games.
Now what's been very successful he use
now with Alphago and um,
the other more complex systems is policy
gradients,
which is a slight variation on this idea
of applying neural networks in this
deeper enforcement learning space.
So dqn is q learning neural network in
the cue learning framework.
It's off policy.
So it's approximating q and infer the
optimum policy,
a policy gradients.
PG is on policy is directly optimizing
the policy space.
Then you'll network as estimating the
probability of taking a certain action
and the learning.
And there's a great,
if you want the details of this from
Andrea Copath is a great post
explaining,
uh,
illustrate it in an illustrative way.
Deeper enforcement learning by looking
at Pong Ping Pong.
So the training process there is you
look at the evolution of the different
games and then reinforce also knows
actor critic.
You take the policy gradient that
increases the probability of good action
and the probability of bad action.
So the policy network is the actor.
So the neural network is the thing that
takes him the raw pixels,
usually a sequence of frames and
outputs,
a probability of taking a certain
action.
So you want to reward actions that have
eventually led to a winning a higher
award and you want to punish the,
you earned two degrees.
You don't have negative gradient for
actions that,
um,
that led to a negative reward.
So the reward there is the critic.
The policy network is the actor,
uh,
the pros and cons of Dqn of Policy
Grazers,
dqn most folks now,
the success comes from policy gradients,
active critic methods,
different variations of it.
The pros are,
it's able to deal with more complex q
function is faster convergence and most,
uh,
in most cases,
given,
given you have enough data,
that's the big con is it's needs a lot
of data.
It needs a lot of ability to simulate
huge,
huge amounts of evolutions of the
system.
And,
uh,
because the model probabilities,
the posse grainy smile at the
probabilities of action,
they're able to,
uh,
learn stochastic policies and Dq cannot.
And that's where the game of go has
received a lot of success with the
application of the policy gradients.
Where at first alpha go in 2016,
beat the top humans in the world,
uh,
at the game of go by training on an
expert,
a games.
So in a supervised way,
starting from training on those human
expert positions and Alphago zero and
2017 achieving a monumental feat.
And in artificial intelligence,
one of the greatest,
in my opinion,
the last decade of training on no human
expert play playing against a itself,
being able to beat under the initial
Alphago and beat the best human players
in the world.
This is an incredible achievement for
reinforcement learning that captivated
our imagination of what's possible with
these approaches.
But the actual approach,
and you can look through the slides as a
few,
uh,
interesting tidbits in there,
but,
uh,
the,
it's using the same kind of methodology
that a lot of game engines have been
using and uh,
certainly goplayers,
uh,
for the Monte Carlo tree search.
So you have this incredibly huge search
space and you have to figure out like
which parts of it do I search in order
to find the good position as the good
actions.
And so there you'll networks I used to
do the estimation of what are the good
actions,
what are the good positions.
Again,
the slides have the fun,
the fun details.
Um,
for those of you who are gambling
addicts,
uh,
importantly,
so,
uh,
the,
the stochastic element of poker,
at least heads up poker.
So one on one has been for the first
time ever this same exact approach had
been used in deep stack and other agents
to beat the top professional poker
players in the world in 2017.
The open challenge for the community,
for maybe people in this room,
uh,
in 2018 is to apply these methods to win
in a much more complex environment of
Terman plate when there's multiple
players.
So heads up poker is a much easier
problem.
Uh,
the human element is much more
formalized bubble and clear there when
there's multiple players,
it's exceptionally difficult and
fascinating.
A fascinating problem that's perhaps
more representative of agents that have
to act in the real world.
So now the Downer part,
a lot of the successful agents that we
work with here at Mit and bill did the
robots that act in the,
in,
in the real world are using almost no
deep reinforcement learning.
So deeper enforcement learning is
successfully applied in context of
simulation in context of game playing.
But in a successfully controlling
humanoid robotics or human robots,
a humanoid robots or autonomous
vehicles,
for example,
the deep learning methods they use
primarily for the perception task.
They're exceptionally good at making
sense of the environment and uh,
extracting useful knowledge from it.
But in terms of forming actions,
that's usually done through optimization
based methods.
Finally a quick comment on the
unexpected local pockets.
That's,
that's at the core of why these methods
are not used in the real world.
Uh,
here is a game of coast runners where a
boat is tasked with receiving a lot of
points.
Traditionally the game is played by
racing other boats and trying to get to
the finish as quickly as possible.
And this boat figures out that it
doesn't need to do that in a brilliant
breakthrough idea.
Uh,
it can just collect a regenerating green
squares.
That's an unintended consequence,
uh,
that you can extend to other systems
perhaps including,
you can imagine what,
uh,
how the,
the cat system over time at the bottom
right can evolve into something
undesirable and further on in these
reinforcement learning agents when they
act in the real world,
the human life is often the human factor
are often injected into the system.
And so oftentimes in their reward
function,
the objective loss function,
you start injecting concepts of risk and
even human life.
So what does it look like in terms of ai
safety when the agent has to make
decision based on a loss function that
includes an estimate or risk of killing
another human being?
This is a very important thing to think
about,
uh,
about machines that learn from data.
And finally a to play around.
There's,
there's,
uh,
there's a lot of ways to explore and
learn about deeper enforcement learning.
And we have at the url below there,
uh,
a deep traffic simulation game.
It's a competition where you get to,
uh,
build a car that speeds,
that tries to achieve the as close to 80
miles per hour as possible.
And I encourage you to participate,
uh,
participate and try to win.
Get it a leaderboard,
not enough mit folks there at the top
10.
So with that,
thank you very much.
Thank you for having me.